in afghanistan the taliban have
announced a caretaker cabinet for their
new government all the posts have been
filled by men mostly long-time members
of the hardline group the international
community had insisted on an inclusive
government otherwise financial aid to
afghanistan would be cut the u.s state
department says it's concerned by the
track records of some cabinet members
now in general it's the old guard of the
taliban regime that will be ruling the
country again
muller hassan akund will be the acting
prime minister he served as foreign
minister in the last uh the last time
the taliban were in power in the 1990s
like many of the incoming cab incoming
cabinet he is under un sanctions
abdul ghani baradar is a co-founder of
the taliban he will be deputy prime
minister he helped lead negotiations
with the u.s to withdraw troops from
afghanistan last year and prior to that
he spent eight years in prison in
pakistan
interior minister sir jaden harkani was
a fierce opponent of the u.s presence in
afghanistan now he's been linked to some
of the most violent terror attacks there
the fbi has issued a 10 million dollar
reward for information leading to his
capture now the taliban say this is an
acting government and deliberations are
ongoing to fill a number of posts that
are still vacant
and joining me now from kabul is
journalist ali latifi
ali the taliban promised a more moderate
rule but the uh interim government is
all male and made up of senior taliban
figures was there ever really a chance
it would be more
inclusive um based on their actions
there definitely was a chance because
they had spent much of the last three
weeks going around meeting with uh
different officials from the previous
government
you know
potentially making deals you know trying
to entice them so there was a hope that
they would somehow include or embrace
these people it's not to say that those
figures
weren't controversial in their own right
for different reasons but the hope was
that if those people could at least come
in
what it would do was um hopefully sort
of mitigate against some of the
taliban's more hard-line stances but if
you look at their current cabinet it's
all
you know old faces uh from their own
rule you know some people even have the
same job they had 25 years ago so
that you know they they hadn't they made
it seem like there was an opportunity
like there was some level of hope
for some kind of inclusion but that
hasn't panned out
so with this new government now in place
what are the taliban's most urgent
priorities
the most urgent priority is the economy
you know um you had said earlier that
the eu wanted to give a billion dollars
in aid to um or a billion euros in aid
to neighboring countries and other
places to keep refugees out
but you know that aid would be much
better spent in the avalon economy to
make sure that people can return to work
that they can access cash in banks
and that they can actually spend money
because the biggest issue right now is
that there is no cash in the in the
market and if you don't have cash you
can't spend money in afghanistan so the
taliban has to convince these countries
and these different financial
institutions these global financial
institutions to bring money back into
afghanistan because if they don't do
that then we're going to continue to see
people waiting hours and days in line at
banks hoping to take out as much money
as they can
while offices and other businesses
remain shuttered because they cannot
afford to pay anybody or they don't have
access to money or people don't have
access money to go out and and spend it
and you know shop and and eat out and
you know buy things um so it's very
important for them to get some kind of
financial
assurance from the rest of the world
okay ali latifi reporting for us from
kabul thanks so much
now as the rush to escape the taliban
intensifies the european union wants to
avoid a repeat of the 2015 migration
crisis when more than a million people
arrived in europe to do so the bloc has
pledged to provide between 600 million
and 1 billion euros now that money will
support charities afghanistan's
neighbors and transit countries to
provide food and shelter to refugees
fleeing the taliban the aim according to
eu leaders is to prevent the recurrence
of uncontrolled large-scale illegal
migration movements faced in the past
and we can speak now to lars
castellucci of the social democrat party
and a member of the german bundestag mr
castellucci thanks so much for joining
us today
how prepared are germany and the eu for
hundreds of thousands more refugees
um
i don't agree that there will be
hundreds of thousands of refugees
so far
the main thing and the most important
thing we have to manage right now is to
at all
get open borders for those who want to
leave the country and this is part of
the negotiations with the taliban
government
but of course many migrants are already
waiting at eu borders wanting to come
what is germany doing to help ease the
situation
well this is again a completely
different question on the eu borders we
need a common
european asylum system that is working
and functioning and this should be based
on solidarity but also on the values
that uh connect us in europe and uh we
have to
um
improve
all the administration regarding
refugees and
distinguish better and faster between
those who
apply for
protection internet international
protection and the others and then
distribute those who
successfully apply for international
protection into the countries in europe
that
allow them to to enter
so obviously improvements need to be
made and yet since 2015 when more than a
million people arrived in europe there's
really been no revised plan created
since then to handle a new refugee
movement why not
because europe is not
in a situation that all the countries
have the common goals and that's a
really deep problem but i don't like the
crisis talk
all in all the situation can be handled
and it can also be handled if countries
a number of countries in europe um take
charge and uh work together and i think
that is what has to be done now
we can't wait for for countries that are
not uh willing to join us in our common
efforts
okay now now turkey became the home of
one of the world's largest migrant
populations back in 2015 but ankara is
now saying it will take no more refugees
what impact would you say that will have
yeah i do understand turkey because they
took over
more migrants than the whole of europe
altogether
and of course we supported them with
billions that went into the country
to build schools to build hospitals and
to support directly
the refugees that stranded in turkey
but we have to negotiate how we can
share the burden on a solidarity
in a solidarity way and that's the
that's the kind of thing that was also
needed before the afghan crisis exploded
in the way that we saw the last couple
of weeks okay lars castellucci of the
social democrats in germany thanks so
much for your time today
thank you
now many afghans believe there is no
safe future for them except outside
afghanistan dw's nick conley met one
family who fled to neighbouring
tajikistan to protect their four
daughters
as an afghan government official
muhammad ahmadi had enough reasons to be
aware of the taliban
but it's his four daughters
two university students and two of
school age and fears for their future
that convince him to leave his country
he tells us
the taliban sent me threats
one of the things they said was that i
should not let my daughters marry
non-believers
instead they said my daughters should
marry young taliban fighters
the decision to leave wasn't taken
lightly the family's eldest too tamana
and kreshma were just months away from
graduating in political science when the
family left this summer
a university education that these young
women had clung to in spite of the odds
continuing with their studies even after
surviving an attack on kabul university
by the so-called islamic state last
november
they had guns and they just came to our
class and started firing at it everyone
they even threw a grenade and
a lot of people was
injured and died there
we escaped from the window but a lot of
our other classmates who couldn't escape
they died unfortunately
we studied together four years three and
a half year and then i just
go after a week there and there's no one
there
taman and kreshma weren't just sisters
and classmates they were also rivals for
the top spot in their degree program
before we met this attack happened in
kabul university the three or
two and a half year of our university
was i could say the best years of our
life that we are studying we were
studying and we were working
on our dreams but after this attack it
was all vanished we was
more like scared
and then hopeful for that aflamestone in
that day
as it later turned out freshman
tamanna's parents had read the signs
correctly
leaving while it was still possible to
board a commercial flight for safety
into jigsaw
most of their classmates have been less
fortunate
a lot of demons have gone on offline
since they have cons since taliban
overtake afghanistan we can find out
where they are actually
their parents who lived through the
taliban's first period in control back
in the 1990s now see history repeating
itself
at a recent demonstration in kabul the
taliban beat the demonstrators until
they bled used tear gas the taliban
still don't respect women
samia spent 30 years teaching in a mixed
sex primary school
her colleagues back in kabul tell her
that this year the girls have not
returned for lessons after the holidays
their parents are just too scared
if it's clear that there's no going back
to afghanistan it's equally clear that
tajikistan is only a temporary stop on
the way to a new life somewhere else
refugees are essentially unable to study
or work in the country which itself sees
hundreds of thousands of locals leave in
search of work abroad every year
all this family can do now is wait and
hope
hope that one of their applications for
resettlement is finally approved